l'ouverture hier à new york au siège de
l'onu du sommet mondial des enfants
conférence de trois jours ou des états
devrait réaffirmer leur engagement en
faveur notamment de la scolarité ou de
la santé depuis longtemps l'unicef mène
campagne pour que les enfants soient
épargnés par la violence dans les pays
en guerre actions de protection action
psychologique aussi exemple à djénine au
lendemain des affrontements
reportage claude son père patrick
démunis un mandat est australienne
depuis trois semaines elle dirige la
mission de l'unicef à jennings dans ce
camp ravagé par les combats et s'occupe
avant tout des enfants
chaque jour elle va rencontrer la
famille de la petite tour à doha a perdu
son petit frère abattu par les soldats
israéliens
il avait 13 ans douvrin a plus une
maison et aujourd'hui quand elle raconte
son histoire
on a l'impression qu'elle récite une
leçon
chaque jour un mandat par le longtemps
desquels pour briser ce discours
elle essaye peu à peu de lui faire
retrouver ses silences et ses émotions
d'enfant
au départ ses enfants parlent comme des
petits durs il parle du combat pour
leurs terres un vrai discours militant
et peu à peu la réalité apparaît leurs
souffrances et on s'aperçoit qu'ils sont
vraiment dans une situation difficile
pour redonner le sourire aux enfants de
djénine l'unicef organise des jeux très
simples les danses et des chants
mais aussi des séances de dessin
un exercice qui permet tout de suite de
voir leurs progrès
moi j'ai vu un dessin la semaine
dernière j'étais là c'était un dessin
avec une école qui avait plutôt l'air
d'une prison avec un temps qui sera lien
avec des corps allongés et la petite
prime expliqué ce qu'elle avait souffert
ce qu'elle avait vu je vais sur la même
petite fille aujourd'hui pouvoir faire
des dessins beaucoup plus naïve cet
après midi là dans le groupe une seule
petite fille va dessiner des images de
guerre un mandala repère tout de suite
et commence à parler avec elle en fin de
journée nous retrouvons un mandat dans
une école de jénine qui vient de
réouvrir cette fois ci avec l'aide de
volontaires palestiniens un mandat
explique aux enfants les dangers liés
aux mines qui traînent encore dans le
camp étrange atmosphère comme quittons
ses enfants ils font tous le v de la
victoire
nous jetons alors un dernier regard sur
le mur du fond de la classe
un mur couvert d' affiches à la gloire
des martyrs et des kamikazes qui ont
connu des affrontements israël